All right, we're ready to go. It is, I don't even know what date it is. What is it? 18th of July, 2018, our Zoom call.
We're going to talk a little bit about genetic testing. So it reminds you what we're looking at when we are going to be doing that.
For you, if we have not done that for you, also reminder this too, if we've already got over your 23 and the details,
and you want to go over it again, you can do that. Just schedule with the office schedule with ads, which you can go over it with you again.
She's the one that's going over that now. She's fully certified in it. Ashley's going to be fully certified within the next week or so.
So it's Michelle. It is a certification process that there's just literally a handful of people in the world that are certified. So I feel very blessed to have three more people in our office that are fully certified to go over genetics when there's literally just five or six dozen people worldwide that really are certified to do so.
So if you want to look at your genetics, if you want to look at something that you maybe forgot or missed, feel free to schedule a time to go over that again.
When we look at genetics, I am sharing my whole screen here because I want to pull up some slides with these are the slides that we go through.
I'll remember on the on when we look at your genetics, there is a whole mess of information on our website.
So if you go to our cutters, clinic website, you will see if you look at Jean's tell stories here, this link right here, it brings you to some very basic information about genetics here.
And then you could go down to cancer genes, the book, which is a series of videos explaining what we're looking at with a cancer patient with their genetics.
So here's the introduction to the book section one section one, the more videos on the gut and what we're looking at with your genetics, cancer diets, energy genes, and it just keeps going and going and this is just going to be an endless stream of videos.
So why did I do that in a series of videos instead of in written material because it's easier to show you on a genetic workup on the what we're going to produce for you because you get a copy of that genetic work up just like what you see on this video, you'll get a copy of this, which is about 60 pages of your genes.
And you could literally go through my videos and look at your printout and learn about your genes and what you need to do and how you can help yourself.
So again, my purpose is try try to empower you to have control.
One of the things that I know that is sometimes easier for us as human beings is that we want to somebody else to solve our problems for us.
And I understand that patients come to our clinic at times that they say here's my disease or here's my problem.
Here you take it. Now I don't have to be responsible anymore and you're responsible to get me better.
Well, a couple of things on that number one, that's not fair. I can't get you better.
My purpose in helping you get better and our clinic's purpose is to try to seek wisdom and we try to seek wisdom from the Holy Spirit in giving you information to help you.
And then what you do with that information, we have literally had people come to us to our whole program, go home and never use the knife and never do their diet and never do their nutrition.
And I know they have it because they never repurchased any products or we get their knife back and I have a way to look at a person's computer and tell if they how much they've actually used it and it's sad sometimes.
But everybody in the flip side and it's not sad. Everybody has a choice to make it. They have to do what they think is right for them.
That is called responsibility and that is called also your power. You don't want to give your power to someone else and I do realize as a human being, it's easier to do that.
I'm going to go to the doctor. He's going to diagnose my condition and that it's his responsibility to get me better by giving me the right medicine or the right drug or the right therapy and no, my problems going to go away.
That is what we've been taught in Western medicine and that is a lie. That's a that's a steal of your power and glowy that to be in someone else's hands and it usually doesn't end well.
So that's not our purpose and I realize that's the that's the perspective that most people are coming from. That's what they've been taught their whole life that I'm they're not a doctor. So that's not their problem.
So when they go to the doctor, it's the doctor's problem to solve their problem and the medical profession is all too eager to take that responsibility because they make a lot of money off of it and they get people dependent upon them.
They can keep a person dependent upon a medication their entire life and there's all sorts of reasons you usually hinted with evil that they want to do that. That's not our purpose.
And I state that from the very beginning, our purpose is to empower you and I realize everybody has a different level of intelligence and a different drive of understanding and not everybody wants to nerd through these videos and listen to them.
And many people want to go just I'm not here to learn everything. You just tell me what to do and we will do that and we will give you our best recommendation, but that's all we can do.
There is there's it's it's often that a person will go through my videos ago. Hey, shouldn't I also be taking procurement because you said on this video this and I have this defect and welcome back and say, well, that might be a good idea.
So that's how we want to empower you.
So please take advantage of that if you can. I also understand if you don't want to, but we give you every tool that I can possibly think of and giving our books away and giving away all this information in these videos and doing these Zoom calls every week to try to empower you to not give your power away.
And I think if you're dealing with something serious like cancer, the more that you could retain that power over your body, the better your going to your better outcomes going to be.
So that's just my belief. You could think otherwise, but I think the more you could control your outcome, the better off it's going to be.
So it is that we're trying to constantly look at new ways to try to help people.
If you've got a hint at my tabs on my when I had my browser open, it's basically all research pieces. So that that's that's all I do in life. And that's what I feel like my purpose is and I'm happy to do it.
And it's it's to help empower more people to take information and make better use of it in their life and hopefully get to the results that they will ultimately knowing that it's all in God's hands and we fall back in the sovereignty of his love for us and his will for us and we can trust that wholeheartedly regardless of what the outcome is going to be.
I do believe it is our responsibility to seek wisdom and to seek knowledge and to walk therein.
So it is we're going to talk about personalized medicine and genetics. Always when we look at genetics, understand.
Epigenetic control trumps our genes most of the time. Yes, if we have a trisomy 21 situation and we're bored with down syndrome, it's really has nothing to do with my diet or chemical exposure, et cetera.
But if I have a trisomy 21 situation and down syndrome diet and chemical exposure and such is going to make my condition worse.
So it though epigenetic control trumps the genetic predisposition most of the time, it's always epigenetic issues affect our genes. What does that mean?
Epigenetic means things that are outside of our genes, things that are environmentally driven that affect our genetics.
So I've talked to people and scientists to say say has nothing to do with our genes, it has everything to do with our diet and our environment and everything.
Well, if you watch any of my videos and understand the genes, you'll understand that is it doesn't make any sense.
If I have defects in my detoxification pathways and I'm exposed to chemical toxins, I'm going to have more of a health risk and issue and increase risk of cancer at all sorts of disease than someone who doesn't have the same genetic defects in detoxification pathways, it is exposed to the same about or even more toxins than I am.
So genetics are extremely important and when we deal with cancer patients, they're even more important because cancer has to do with certain carcinogens in our environment that affect us like this slide, all different things epigenetically that are affecting us.
And something getting inside the cell and causing a replication increase in replication rate, what's supposed to happen is that we have these genes called tumor suppressor genes that are supposed to kick on in that case of sensing rapid replication.
And they should cause a death of that cell or increase a popotic rate of that cell or the cells that we're talking about.
If I have defects in those tumor suppressor genes, I'm going to have a much greater chance of not putting the brakes on that cancer.
Because remember, everybody has cancer, everybody has this issue inside of a cell at any given time that's damaging the replication rate and the replication rate starts to go crazy and the cell starts to replicate that is cancer, but our immune system that is supposed to recognize that and kill it and we never get a diagnosis of cancer.
That's what's taking place constantly in everybody, even if they don't have a cancer diagnosis.
What's helping that immune system recognize that cell that's in rapid replication is that tumor suppressor system.
And I say system because there's hundreds of genes that are involved in the tumor suppressor rapid replication cycle of any given cell.
So if I have defects in certain sets of groupings families of those genes, I'm going to have an increased risk of cancer developed and getting out of control and be getting a diagnosis of cancer when that does happen.
So we do want to look at those tumor suppressor genes as well as detox genes as well as dietary genes as God health genes and all the things that we look at when we look at your genetics, those are all very important.
One common question that we get when we look at genes is how early should I look at genes, should we start looking at my kids genes, they're only 11 years old, should we look at their genes.
My belief is the earlier that we can look at someone's genetic predisposition without scaring them, but we can look and say, wow, your son has the same pod one defects that you do, that's a genetic family that pod one pathway is responsible for many things but one thing it's responsible for is detoxing heavy metals and pesticides and chemicals and vaccinations.
So if you knew that your 11 year old had a lot of defects on that pathway, you could make lifestyle changes like wow, we're not going to do vaccines on him.
We are not going to, we are going to be very careful with additives, flavorings, colorings, we're going to not spray pesticides and insecticides on our lawn, we are going to use only natural bunk killers in our house.
Everybody should be doing those things maybe every all already, but knowing your genetics can kind of give you a motivational push to do to make certain environment.
There's certain environmental changes around you that could help prevent disease in the future and I think that's invaluable.
So it's not about oh my gosh, you have the broccotugin defect, you're going to get cancer, it's oh my gosh, you have the broccotugin defect, you have to be more careful with your environment than someone who doesn't have the broccotugin defect.
That's what it's looking at gives you motivational push to do the right thing.
So it's not just tumor suppressor genes, when we look at the folate pathway, the metiety pathway, the transformation pathway and you know all the other iron pathways copper pathways, it gives us a big broad picture of things that you can change maybe a supplement that would be really good for it.
Maybe a supplement that you really should stay away from that can that can help you live not just cancer free, but more disease free in the future know how to where you have weaknesses and where you have strengths.
It's just like doing a personality profile at your job, here's your strength finder profile, here's really where your strengths are, here's where your weaknesses are, maybe we need to strengthen those weaknesses or shore those up so that it doesn't cripple you in your job performance.
It's the same thing with your genetics, here's your strengths, here's your weaknesses, you got serious weaknesses on these detox pathways, we want to support those by really you should be a milk this or this product on a regular basis couple times a week for your life and that's going to really help prevent toxic exposure so that's the way to look at your genes.
In a healthy state and certainly in a disease state, where do we need to support things to help things move a little better that's really what we call personalized medicine and I think it can get much more personalized than that.
We don't want to just look at somebody in a disease state and try to fix them we want to look at why they're in that state and even from a functional medicine standpoint we used to do testing to see oh this person's got mercury toxicity that's why they have the symptoms so we're going to detox the mercury.
Is it even a little bit deeper to see wow why do they have mercury toxicity well they're exposed to the vaccines or they had mercury fillings of their mouth well yes but going a little bit deeper looking at the genes they have all these pond one defects that's why they can't get rid of mercury so if we support that pond one pathway also knowing that there's a whole lot of things that are environment that you can't stay away from even if you try.
You can at least have a better chance in your body to get rid of those things when you're exposed to it and that's where genetics really give us a shining example so make sure you go to our website and watch these videos I mean it is going to be a requirement and my staff is trained now before your genetic review you've got to start watching some of these videos okay so.
So it's really important because I know doing over 500 genetic reviews in the last few years it's very frustrating since I did make some of these videos I hear some I think this page here there's I have so many videos I mean I have about 300 videos but here on this page the genetic slip testing I have some very generalized videos.
What is the videos of what how to order your 23 be what is a step what are a step basics what are what's the MTHFR gene that everybody talks about and so this really helps you understand some of the basic things and even if you don't want to nerd out on these things it's a lot easier to go over somebody's genetics when they spent a little bit of time understanding the genetics.
terminology so that when we do go over it it's not like a deer in the headlights because I do know what's isn't the language and it's it's difficult to understand sometimes the more you can understand about your health the greater control you're going to have over it and the better results you're going to get.
Okay so some questions that came in one question was what's your opinion on the supplement to read to read is an amino acid.
This person says I read that people at a vegetarian diet should use this to read in order to help the detox pathways in the body.
On the other side of different things that Tori is phoned in Tori is considered a non essential amino acid.
So amino acids are categorized as essential and non essential so amino acids that are essential means that you need to get them in your diet because your body can't make them.
Non essential amino acids means that your body can make them from other amino acids and from other proteins.
So Tori is considered a non essential amino acid some people have a more difficult time making certain amino acids so that can be a problem and certain animals I know have a difficult time making Tori like cats have to get Tori through their diet.
They should be able to make Tori normally through other amino acids that they consume but if you are a vegan especially and you're not eating any of these things you're not getting Tori in your diet.
Now these are just the most common sources of Tori if you're eating eggs but you're not eating dairy and meat you're getting plenty of Tori.
Tori has good and bad things just like everything else it's all about balance remember there's no such thing as a good day in a bad day generally it's about balance when we're talking about specific nutrients that your body needs.
The good about Tori is Tori helps with muscle contraction Tori helps with detoxification because it aids a phosphatidol calling and production of bile so it does help with the detoxification phase 3 detox in your liver.
The bad about Tori is that Tori is a stimulant it's a stimulant to your cardio muscles it's also used as a neurotransmitter in your brain and it's a stimulatory neurotransmitter.
Now we've talked a lot about stimulatory neurotransmitters when we spoke about glutamate so glutamate is also a stimulatory neurotransmitter.
Tori is used probably the most common source of Tori that you see is in energy drinks so like Red Bull and those energy drinks have a lot of Tori because Tori is an excitatory neurotransmitter.
So it just like turns your brain on that's what helps wake you up right so when you drink shoot out a Red Bull you got caffeine in it and you have Tori in it which is highly stimulatory to your brain.
Well the danger of stimulatory neurotransmitters to your brain is you literally fry out those pathways and you can severely damage your brain and increase Alzheimer's risk.
So I'm not a fan of supplemented Tori as a supplement you could go to your local health food store or go on Amazon and search for Tori and you'll have a whole bunch of supplements that are you know 100 milligrams of Tori that are a milligram dose they come in because I've never sold them.
I'm not a fan of that you the issues other than brain issues which is bad enough is you could have heart issues with it. I remember one time they were giving samples of an energy drink this is the first time energy drinks are out this is probably 10 years ago in a local ball and I took one of these energy drinks it was literally a half an ounce
a little teeny little glasses that they were little cups like communion cups that they were giving it it it I sampled it and my heart rate went like through the roof for about 20 minutes.
I have a sensitivity Tori to obviously but so I've never had one of those energy drinks except for that half an ounce that I consumed that one day because I feel like my heart wasn't going to explode.
It's it's highly it's a strong strong stimulant and you have to be careful with those with that I'd much rather have you get the majority of your meat you know assets through your food or through a plant based protein like the one we have on our store.
Other questions that came in what causes capillary fragility he magiomas that's what you get bruised and such does histamine intolerance contribute to this well good question because histamine excess histamine does cause an increase capillary fragility so excess histamine people have issues with their H and M T gene that's the gene that makes the DAO ends I'm in the tissue to get rid of histamine of the gene.
They get rid of histamine of the tissue people that have a lot of defects on their H and M T genes have a increase problem with histamine levels in their body and a lot more highly reactive to bug bites and and skin rashes and skin reactions and sinus issues and things like that all the issues of high histamine levels.
And they can have increase capillary fragility so yes that's a piece there's a whole bunch other pieces of capillary fragility but that is just that is another one.
How do you choose a good coconut oil does it should it be organic extra virgin cold press unrefined what does the process better yes it's very difficult to that's the same problem that we haven't choosing just about any food out there I would say I would pick organic first.
So I know there's other people and say oh you should only get coconut oil that's in a dark jar because coconut oil is stable in a clear plastic jar yes that is true it's but it also depends on how long it's been on the shelf personally we get our coconut oil at Costco it's organic in Costco flies through their merchandise so it's never
sitting on the shelf and then we keep it at a dark cupboard so it isn't exposed to sunlight true rife has new updates with new frequency with new frequency delivery systems in their hyper drive etc.
Should we update our programs yes I think that you should update your true rife programs about every three to six months however that's really only if you're using other programs then the ones that we made for you.
When you update your true rife programs it will not change the programs that we made for you it will change if they made any changes like made any changes to other programs and that's a good thing because he's updating and tweaking different frequencies and different programs are adding programs.
So if you're not ever using any other programs then the ones that we created you there is no ever reason for you to update your your true rife program personally my rife at home I have it updated for years because I'm only running the programs that I've created.
Many of our patients are only running the programs that I've created for them so there's really no need for them to update their programs if you're frequently using other programs in your rife system which we encourage you to do so then about every three to six months you're going to want to update the frequencies and it to update the frequencies I don't have right on this computer that I'm on right now so I can't show you but you literally open up any program.
Your rife the computer we're talking about the computer that your rife is on so the computer that you got from our office has to be connected to the internet to do this you cannot update the rife program if it's not connected to the internet because it's updated through the internet so if you're connected to the internet you open up the computer you go to any rife program and you'll see on the top tab bar update frequencies.
and let it go through its sequence you might have to hit yes a couple times and it'll update it takes about five minutes and it's all updated that's how simple it is.
Concerning the secrets machine can we do repeating programs for two to three sessions of one through ten yes you can you can't overdo those programs you could do multiple sessions a day
and for those who don't know what the secrets is we have some people that have a home secrets at home this person does it's a wonderful low frequency P E of F machine that is running specific frequency similar to the rife machine through a different mechanism it's I love the secret machine it's fantastic so it's a great tool to be doing at a regular basis Stanley basis personally whatever I go to the system.
The secret machine has my staff I fall asleep so it's very relaxing to me and it's a great machine so you can't really overdo it with your programs all right so I'm going to open you up to questions and unmute everybody so if anybody has any questions now is the time to speak up.
Because this is down I went to the store and right now all the summer produces out and really really relatively cheap organic ones is it okay to buy in bulk and cut it all up and freeze it in freezer bags and does the freezer bag.
So you can speak and speak and speak into the food no I don't think it does the plastic plastic has as dangerous because plastics end up causing issues with estrogens in our body and can stimulate bad estrogen production in our body and lead to concerns so plastics I'm not a big fan of it really plastic.
So if you're not putting hot food in the freezer bags you're just putting peppers in a freezer bag and speak in the freezer you're really going to have very little plastic exposure.
There's some people that would say if you really what no plastic exposure put it the glass they could put it in the freezer I don't know how you don't have to get some sort of Pyrex freezer proof container to do that.
And if you really want to be perfect that that probably be the perfect thing to do we put our vegetables we have a big guarded.
Chop up peppers by way did it for freezer bags and did that I don't see any bigger harm.
Thank you.
Any other questions?
This is Sharon when I got evaluated it's like based on some of the items that you test for you didn't you were not able to determine my cause of cancer and does that mean you'll never be able to or.
No, if you were to be back here we could test you again it might that might show up.
We've even had people as we test them another time another thing comes up remember like I've always said everybody has multiple causes of their cancer there's multiple layers to.
To our issues that we have so it's so let's say a person comes up as pesticide the cause of the cancer but there's probably I mean always stress is a piece of it so there's always emotional pieces of the cause of our cancer there's also causes of why by immune system did it kill this when it started growing which could be a genetic piece.
To the suppressor genes that I mentioned earlier on this call can be other issues tobacco toxins that are suppressing my immune system or something that's affecting my my sympathetic parasympathetic response it just goes on and on and on the layers of pieces that are causes.
The reason why some people you're not the only person that we can't find the specific cause is that it's it's not really one specific cause it's just a conglomeration of a bunch of different things so it's like your body wouldn't tell us.
The one thing because it's almost like your body said that's not important that it's it's too complex it's it that's so just move on and figure out how you're going to correct this so I wouldn't say it's always it's it's always going to come up but there's a chance let's say you came back in the office tomorrow we test you that's something would come up.
It has every has any is everybody watched a lot of these genetic videos or is this new is this new information to you I watch the sniff one before my.
This one right here.
What's a step.
The one that you had just explained the whole background okay.
And this is down I watched the ones that are on.
Pretend to the supplement you put this on you put me on I watch those.
I put the sniff ones I started with the basics and then went to those with my supplement this hour and six minute one is what I created.
I don't know it was maybe a couple years ago be going through a genetic profile and now the report is about two times or more longer than this one is as we're constantly updating the software and pulling more data from the 23 me into this.
But this really gives you a real good idea how we go through it.
I mean literally it takes a good hour or so for us to go through this and through your data prior to us getting on the phone with you and make your recommendations and then it takes time to put those together afterwards.
So it's it's a good several hours worth of work on our part to do that so it's just easier if you have kind of done a little bit of homework so you're not asking questions that you have been answered multiple times on these videos or it just helps you.
Again, it empowers you and that's what we're trying to do is give you that that information see that you.
Because I think a big part of any disease is fear and that's I think with the more information that you have that can help dispel some of that.
And that's that's when our purpose is here so.
And so make sure you.
You take a peek at some of those.
Conners, this is crystal and I have a question.
You had said when I was in there about my genetic testing that some of the genetics defects that I have might possibly be passed down to my children.
They would like to take a 23 in me test is there some place they can go to have this into them.
I mean, do you guys do that for someone who is impatient?
Yeah, we do.
So if somebody calls us up off out of the blue, they don't know us from who but they maybe saw one of my videos on YouTube or something like that and they.
This is really common so we get people that contact us and say, oh my gosh, I saw a lot of doctor cutters videos and I did my 23 me a year and a half ago and my doctor read it and gave me a one page sheet of the answers and it didn't help me at all.
And his videos talk about a 60 page report that you guys go through and how do I get that because again, not to knock other doctors out there, but if you don't understand how to read your genetics, you're just looking at a few genes and then making a physical assessment on a patient.
It's, it's just silly some of the recommendations that we hear so you want to take as big a step back as possible and look at as many genes as possible to get a bigger picture as possible to help that patient the best way possible.
And if you don't do that, you're you're missing a lot so if that if a person calls us out of the blue, there is a process that they have to go through, we have to do a case review because we want to get to know that person.
And then we go do a review with them, which is over a zoom call all of them are done over zoom calls and we do the same thing is what we do what we're doing for you.
But there's a greater fee for it. So our patients that are that have family members that want to do this. We have a discounted fee. So we have what's called a family fee.
And Jed or one of the girls to explain that to you, which is literally half price.
So it's cost you a few hundred dollars to go through that for your family members.
We'll do it for all your family members for half price. Yes, that's exactly right.
So we try it. I just think it's a bar is done and we need to get Alex and understand Heather out of get hers done. So should tell you. Yeah. So you it's just invaluable to go through this. Now understand, if it's an 11 year old boy, we're going to go over that 11 year of boys.
It could be invaluable for kids and for family members. So we really want to we really want to make that available.
Okay. Thank you. All right. Any other questions before we sign off for tonight.
Dr. Connor, this is Patty Ross. I do have a question about how young. Like what is the.
Well, the biggest thing is is ability to get a sample.
As soon as you can get the child to be able to spit in the bottle. That's right. Okay.
So you have to they have to be of an age and understanding that they're going to that they're going to be able to spit in the thing. You know, you could collect a sample.
You could certainly purchase a 23 and be kicked and then try it and then sit it in it.
And if they don't get enough saliva, they will notify you and they will send you another kit to collect more that saliva.
So you can try it again. And if it doesn't work again, they'll send you another kit. And then you can just save it.
I can't turn it off.
Also a note on that is that 23 and the people have this question all the time.
I don't want 23 and me to see to have my genetic data because they could sell it.
And my comment is, how does 23 and me know it's your genetic data?
The only way they know it is because you gave them your name.
So if you feel and don't tell me, I'm telling you this because they probably get mad at me.
But if you felt like that that you don't want anybody else to know your genetic data because you plan on committing a horrible crime, you know, a year and you want them to find out it was you then it was a good reason.
But let's begin. You don't want anybody to find out your genetic data.
So just use a fictitious name and create a new email because your email is going to be the your user name and then you create a password with 23 and me.
So just use if you don't want them to have your child's data that you're afraid they're going to sell it. Now, there's new laws that are preventing them from doing that like they used to a few years ago.
But if you still don't trust them, which maybe you don't, just write down a different name.
You have to tell us what that name is. It will go in as your name in our software, but understand our software is our software. Nobody else can be able to see it. So
your data is protected through the PMA. So nobody can even request your information in it.
So even if even if some governmental agency called us or said doesn't let her requested all your information for some reason, be through the pastoral medical association.
That's one of the great things about being a part of it is that all your records are sealed. I don't care who they are. They don't get your records.
And nobody's going to see your genetic stuff but us. So it's all same.
Okay. Any other questions?
The red button on it for about 10 seconds. And then.
Okay.
All right. So we're going to close it up for tonight. And remember to send your Zoom call questions into counters clinic at gmail.com.
And write a little heading in the info bar that it is a Zoom call question so that we see that.
We will be able to get your call question on our slide and be able to answer those hopefully as best I know how.
And we'll see you guys next week.
All right.